when I think of justice I think of
something that's not all that much
different from respect for individual
rights now in this respect that I speak
not simply about the civil and political
rights that for I think many Americans
are conjured up by the concept of rights
it's not simply the rights that are in
the US Constitution that is to say but
also some basic economic justice some
basic respect for what are known as as
economic and social rights in the
international realm but that is to say
at the minimum the provision of the
necessities of life the the housing the
food the medical care and the like that
allow people to exist and live with some
basic dignity so I do think that with
that holistic concept of Rights that
there's not all that much difference
between justice and respect for rights
but I do think to to equate the two you
have to move beyond the more
procedurally oriented rights of say the
US Constitution of Civil and Political
Rights and look at some of the more
substantive rights